talk to me about this new Online safety
bill you say is going to protect
children but we've strengthened it for
children so everything that was in it
before in relation to children that
means that if the content is illegal it
has to go it means that if it's harmful
but still legal it has to go and
companies will face a humongous fines if
they breach these terms up to 10 of
their Global turnover the ways that
we've strengthened it that I've done are
we're making sure that they have to
adhere to their age restrictions we know
they all set 13 as an age but we don't
that they don't enforce it so you get 10
year olds 11 year olds 12 year olds on
those platforms so what we say is they
have to have mechanisms by which to stop
kids younger going like age Assurance
age verification Etc and they have to
explain to the public and to parents how
they're doing that in their terms and
conditions and again if they fail to do
that they could face the sanctions we're
also saying that the regulator of com
has to work with the children's
Commissioners that children's Voice is
coming out and when social media
platforms do risk assessments into
illegal content and harmful content they
also have to provide summaries publicly
so that everybody knows again what
they're saying so they can no longer be
a closed shop they can no longer be
these nameless faceless Executives in
Silicon Valley that are making decisions
about your children everybody else's
children sure I mean we've been chatting
to the shadow cultures actually Lucy
Powell she says it's a major weakening
of the bill replacing the prevention of
harm with an emphasis on Free Speech
undermines in quoting her the very
purpose of this bill oh I'm sure she
hasn't properly had time to to go
through the bill because when she does
she will understand actually what we've
done is strengthen it have run through
the strengthens for children then for
adults we've introduced a triple shield
first shield is if the content is
illegal has to go I before second Shield
is if it's contrary to their terms and
conditions it has to go we know that
covers the vast majority of things when
we think back to 100 with the
footballers in a poster Euros with the
racist or rendous abuse they got that
was either a legal or contrary to terms
of conditions they just don't enforce
them versus a Monday versus a Tuesday
it's a different kind of approach and
we're going to stop that from happening
and the third incorporate harm from but
not illegal because of course your team
so what we're doing is we're removing
legal but harmful but the third Shield
that we're doing is a safeguarding
mechanism a further safety net so that
it empowers individuals to have more
control over the content that they see
it gives them the choice so it's freedom
of choice and freedom of speech whilst
also offering those three Shields of
protection why take out harmful but not
illegal because it had very very
concerning
um uh impact potentially on Free Speech
there are unintended consequences
associated with it it was really the
anchor that was preventing this bill
from getting off the ground it was a
creation of a quasi-legal category
between illegal and legal that's not
what a government should be doing it's
confusing it would create a different
kind of set of rules online to offline
in the legal sphere personally I think
you know if we all agree that stuff
should be illegal let's make it illegal
that's what we've done with this bill
now for the first time ever the
promotion of self-harm will be made
illegal and that's something that we've
added to this bill in the last couple of
months whilst an organization that knows
a lot about that is the Samaritans they
say taking legal but
um uh harmful but not legal out is a
hugely backward step
um but they've also campaigned for the
promotion of self-harm to be made
illegal which is something that we've
done and as I said before we've
introduced this triple Shield so if the
content is illegal it goes if it's
contrary to their terms and conditions
it goes and then there's an additional
safety mechanism where platforms do have
to provide more choice to individuals
over the content that they see so this
is all encompassing but fundamentally
it's about children and we're really
strengthening those aspects how are you
feeling about Elon Musk and his new look
Twitter well look he's a an individual
that's purchased a private business but
it's important that we have those
Safeguard mechanisms around it so and no
matter what direction he wants to take
Twitter in we will have this triple
shield in place for adults and he will
have to adhere to the new rules for
children to safeguard them yeah what do
you think about some of the choice
characters that he's allowing back on
Twitter again you know that is a
decision for him I do believe in free
speech I passionately believe it is the
Cornerstone of our democracy but I also
believe in Freedom of Choice which is
why we've added that Safeguard
mechanisms you will have more Choice
over the content that you see I believe
that people shouldn't be subjected to
Illegal content and and I believe that
if a company is going to say that
they're going to do something they
should actually do it and they shouldn't
be conning people in terms of conditions
that aren't actually then enforced
um it's a big day today as you know for
both England and Wales fans as we know
one of your ministers Stuart Andrew the
sports Minister openly gay he's going to
Qatar he's wearing his one love and he
says do you support him in that 100 I
support the uh the campaign behind it
and the sentiment behind the one love
armband and I believe in us being able
to stand up for our values and I'm proud
that he's going to wear that would you
wear one if you went yes I think I would
actually
okay I'm only asking because Tony Blair
has said we shouldn't be pushing Kata
too far because they invest very heavily
in the UK been doing a bit of research
on that with the team this morning their
own Harrods The Shard
um the Savoy 20 stake in Heathrow 14
stake in Sainsbury's we don't really
want to upset them
well I mean I think that that this is
not about pushing them this is about
standing up your own values and uh and
your country's values I fully backed uh
the English and the Welsh teams uh
desire to wear the the bands too
obviously they were curtailed from doing
that because they would have faced very
punitive sport sanctions but you know
it's imperative that we use our voice
that we stand up for our values not just
in the UK but on the global stage okay
given that Golden Era of relations with
China is over says Rishi sunak yesterday
is China a threat or a challenge these
days because you described it as a
challenge last night in the summer when
I interviewed him he talked about it as
a threat I think we can get a little bit
hung up on the semantics here but what
he said last night was it's um does
present strategic challenges and he
talked about the fact that we've got to
have our eyes open we can't forget the
fat or underestimate the fact that
they're a massive Global player and that
we do need to engage with them but at
the same time we've got to do that as I
say with our eyes open they have two
percent strategic charges and we will um
be updating the integration did review
in the spring so we don't need to see
them as a threat though well as he said
last night they're a strategic challenge
but let's not threat in the summer well
let's I mean I think we're a little bit
talking of semantics here type of
challenge I mean they're very similar a
similar language too much on on the
prime minister's choice of phrase you
know he did a very detailed speech last
night where he outlined his position I
see some of my colleagues there's a
challenge but I don't see them as a
threat well look uh he outlined his his
full position uh last night the full
speeches is available to read I think it
was very comprehensive and clear where
he was coming from and we'll be updating
the integrated review in the new year I
just saw in the papers this morning that
you were commenting on the fact that
Westminster Hall had been damaged during
the Queens lying in state because the
carpet was glued to the floor how much
is it going to cost to fix it I don't
think we have a figure at the moment but
obviously we did everything we could to
make sure that
um people were able to pay their
respects and mourn the queen and and it
was very successful in that vat
um and also you know they were they were
able to participate and felt like they
thought whatever the costume was worth
it well no I wouldn't say that but I
don't think anybody's questioning
whether people should have had the
opportunity to see the queen but don't
come along with Gorilla Glue and stick
down the carpet look I don't think
anybody's questioning that people should
have had the opportunity to to say
goodbye to our late Monarch who was
arguably one of the best in our history
as a nation
um any damage will will of course be
covered and I'm sure that we can come
back to you with these advocacy okay